this is dungeons dungeons and more
dungeons I cast broom of doom
I cast Dipper hat I'm just gonna wear
those all the time now
sister Sunday gave me this cast fairy
dust bunnies hahahahahaha seriously uh
is this uh goddamn I love the show
fucking damn it alum basho every time it
comes on it's like shit I love the show
I mean this isn't even one that relieved
it shows much of the mystery anything
but it's just so insanely entertaining I
love these people and I love the
environment and I love the comedy and I
love the writing and I love the voice
acting goddamn it um okay sorry
just have to get that out there um so
this is Anna bus I love the way it's so
perfectly encapsulated why I never
played Dungeons and Dragons yeah nothing
against people who um not at all but
it's so it literally never meant for me
what they were talking about like oh my
god this sounds like homework yes a
homework the game I think that was the
one time like pointed at Neyland yeah
that's just yet so we can see you there
you um it's just big perfect keep it
like that uh yeah I mean for me that is
always when I play a game I just want to
not think I'm yo I play like a
side-scroller shoot him up or something
like that or maybe a board game but
anything that was that she's just
talking to Brad about this like anything
that's like you know thinking of
requires like too much too much
intelligence don't get me wrong it it
sounds like really bad oh you don't want
to think kinda yeah I really don't want
to but um well my problem is it I
there's nothing wrong if you do it keep
that brain going keep it thinking please
I mean it's a zoo animal um rules but
the thing that kind of irks me the most
about it is uh the element of luck
others me with the dice that's always
kind of way more like really that's our
so we work so hard to come up with all
these rules of this crazy to do just
comes down to rolling dice wait but you
like and risk isn't that kind of the
same thing it just comes down to alarms
yeah but this and a bunch of fucking
rules to risk it's pretty cut-and-dry
you take over the world
yeah just take over the world so it's
it's pretty idiot-proof um so yeah I
don't know I don't know if there's a way
around that
I I feel like this is why I enjoy
something like you know role-playing
games like on a console or you know
computer more where it's just like okay
it's not just luck you have to build up
some sort of set of skill which you can
build up sets of skills with it it's
still it's not a roll of the dice like
what and then they gotta get a little
bit of LARPing in there too uh would you
I can tell you at the end I was like a
loving tribute or like really even I
mean I'm not like well that's kind of
harsh you can figure this out yeah I
felt the same thing I'm like wow that's
a doctored up to think maybe you know
we're just using fantasy as an escape
and I was like whoa it's like fortresses
can't talk
yeah um I like the little so but on top
of that on top of being just so funny
just to reiterate it I have no problem
with dungeons during I have no problem
with LARPing I different strokes for
different folks
yeah it's like the pony thing if you
like ponies great I I don't believe this
way it's held my saying but you do
nothing wrong I'm sitting here with a
broom in my hand and a pot on my head I
have a dipper hat we clearly have our
weird obsession yeah we clearly are not
ones to judge others which they also
really well addressed in they we don't
meta yeah there's a lot of jokes what
like - yeah it's a kid show but there's
a lot of jokes I go over adults hands
and there's a great mystery in Vice the
one where I was kind of like yeah you
did me there was the twin brother thing
like I get it cuz I'm sure people are
going on the internet like woo um boss
they're nice way of just saying they
don't give a shit
yeah like watch us anyway we were really
good well before I actively make fun of
you yeah um but yeah yeah weird al'
yankovic as uh what the hell is he
called again in profit or a profit or
some like that and was I and always
heard it was a princess
unattainable yeah fine princess
unattainable and then the hot elf who's
just called hot elf um it's like over in
stuff that's Elsie whatever the the 90s
trivia there you know whatever I see
that people make fun of a 90
and so I'm like y'all when they try to
get hip and extreme it is one of those
things where it's like there's I'm so
glad some of that's over we see like no
no I'm glad that people are dressing
like yeah this was stupid like grabbing
following that don't get America will
wise up there wasn't part whereas
younger let's just listen those words
all go baby sis all just gonna be like
this yo-yo did the dungeons in all day
yeah it's just one of the things when I
was younger I just really thought oh my
guys it's just we're all entertainment
is going and all these really good stuff
isn't really coming out anymore no
because to be cool it's like to know it
just rubs the kids who grew up in the
90s now look back and I realize how
fucking stupid yeah I guess like the
sixties or seventies we had the
disadvantage of we were already like
halfway into our teen years so we
already were like this is stupid as we
lived it but yeah yeah the kids now have
like grown up and put it back and see
how much they were being played just
like we look back and looking like
transformers and be like yeah I guess it
was really just a Celtic but I'm still
nostalgic right shit I love it she'll
still put on like I just tidy to desert
I thought the same way those differences
like wow the 90s must have been a dark
time yeah you know they half of the kids
like yeah it was fun
parts are amazing things like Jurassic
Park and like but even the ninety stuff
I don't like you know we're nostalgic
again Simpsons did it perfect with
Poochie I think that encapsulate
everything it was yeah I think I lost it
like the mid-90s when they did the
Chuckie Cheese commercials with him eat
him so read rollerblader and I'm like no
everybody was mad too I'm like now I'm
like he's this is fucking Chuckie Cheese
don't try to make him him we get more of
sort of the separation between uh Mabel
and dipper so sad I like because it
wasn't like it was there you couldn't
not see it but it wasn't to hammer dance
now like - oh just an episode is gonna
be that you can sort of tell it's going
to be over time porn I like that though
I like because I like there you know I
like their friendship and their and
their comradery and everything so much
that the idea seeing is slowly break up
it's like I can tell I'd be like oh I
don't want to see that happen bond the
other hand that'd be so fascinating to
see because I just see them as
such a duo um so I'm really doing I'm
getting all sad about them I'm like oh I
like we get more for Tammy we have a new
character pretty much and Stan's brother
um which is great and he's again it's
I'm glad he's not just a
stick-in-the-mud like when he brings out
the game he's like you know oh my god we
gotta play this and we want everyone
making love what I loved about the
episode is how they all came together at
in the end yeah they also dangerous not
just about math there's also risk and
imagination at risk imagination I did
the fight the fight thing about that is
that it actually did remind me um the
first time I went to a con and I heard
there was a card room I'm just like you
know like our games and stuff like oh
great I thought was gonna be poker
that's real like I was really excited I
go whoa dudes are magic it's really like
really I've never been to a con before
so what I went real Renick on in Vegas
it's the only excuse you could ever
think I don't know I play poker like in
you know just bars and stuff I mean like
whatever just it's you know you just
don't say it but yeah I guess it
wouldn't be like an official say they'd
have to have like a boat attached to my
car dude I'm sitting here with a metal
bowl over my head and I think that's
pretty dumb I it's my first cod I didn't
know even once a lot they're still oh
pardon me that goes off when I hear like
the cardroom like oh yeah that's with
immature thing that five is just funny
um but yeah I think I didn't want to
note something though I felt that for
all the talk about dungeons dungeons and
more dungeons
there was a glaring hole which is she uh
Mabel came up with the bouncy shoes but
then she also came up with a bunch of
flaming swords I didn't see a role for
that I'm just saying I didn't see her
role for that I just assumed I think
teaching like I didn't understand I was
kind of thinking that shit I think I
didn't grow I I think I think they
cheated just like grunkle Stan cheated
with the dice and the gum I think she
like just pulled it up I did I surprised
Weird Al Yankovic the wizard there was
like hey wait a second you never roll
but you know it's dungeons and dungeons
and more dungeons real-life urge maybe
the rules are a little different maybe
that's the more dungeons part you get
three moves and amy was it yes
do it oh no I don't know the rules God
knows our gonna have a rule book for
this low volume what that's been paid to
rules volume 1 yeah well what's the line
from Bob's Burgers uh oh my god why am i
analyzing this oh my god why my sister
the was it the brony episode something I
hate whisker nuts
no equesticles or whatever no that's
those those are the fans who are male I
thought oh yeah uh but yeah this is uh
it's mostly just kind of a fun episode
but it was so much fun and I don't
really follow D&D or a lot of those
games but I thought they so well
represent both sides of the people that
just don't care and kick it into it but
also like oh but I decide to get any
little fun that was even more yeah and
they also like I totally agree I have
never gone I am NOT a D&D person I I got
roped in by a friend to going to some
magic game down in the basement of a
comic book shop and I could tell you not
for me I was never more freaking bored
in my entire life and this is back when
it was this was like the mid late 90s or
something but the thing is I I'm like
hey I'm glad they're having fun I mean
it's like video games I mean if you like
video games great if somebody does it
it's not like what the fighting or if
you do like video what the fuck's wrong
again no go ahead many different phones
say yeah there's nothing wrong with it
so I have friends who play D&D and I'm
like that's cool more power to them I'd
been asked for a mic I'm good you know I
think I like because it very accurately
shows both sides of like why people
would be intuitive why people would not
be into well I like that if for all the
making fun of the man that got the
imagination and that part of it cuz
that's what appeals to me the most it's
you know all the rules in the dye don't
really like but you know the
storytelling aspect I think is cool so
yeah um so yeah it's fine if a wants
like you know you sort of appear to hey
well football we're fucking where we go
while we're wearing anywhere we're not
gonna be wants to talk about that no you
should take us seriously a ten-second
yeah we don't care if you like we know
we're friends lots of people that are
into it stuff like that it's just not
our thing if you like have fun it's a is
probably a thinking person's game I'm
sure
and a lot of imagination stuff it's yeah
it's just not for us yeah doing our fan
base or even come in and be like get a
life yeah come on guys
Who am I fighting the play tons it's a
drag it's come on weirdos in our differe
head and pull hat and broom swords oh oh
so sweater watch or swatch as I like to
call it swatch 2015 uh we started off
with a puzzle piece some puzzle pieces
um then the duck-tective right there was
the duck-tective at the end and then
there was like some sort of night gown
shoes ring I swear was like a old floppy
Dale you know that's always when I catch
you and say yeah I don't look at my
woman said before not really she's had
their I think from like episode what I
think never noticed that I wasn't
initially looking at like trying to pay
attention to the sweaters from episode
now it's like a fake yeah now I'm like
now like if I'm worried there's gonna be
more than one sweater and after remember
them I'm like really paying attention to
what she's wearing I did not get a
chance to look up the code this time but
if we have like a million v-log so shoot
today so we're just trying to run
through oh no I do the research that's a
season really in honor of the dungeons
and dungeons and more dungeons that
you're supposed to do math and codes and
stuff like that go find out the code for
yourself or maybe I'll just say in the
next one who knows oh I thought this is
a really good episode yeah I it was just
a lot of fun it had you know little dabs
of the mystery but not too much it was
really just sort of a fun episode which
is nice to return to and I'm totally
comfortable with this you know with
Stan's brother being a part of a cast
now I think he's a he's a lot of fun
dude I'll miss the dipper Mabel but I
thought they resolved that nicely in
this ones Oh bill it seems like they're
keenly aware of what they're doing so
yeah I mean it's enough I'm not worried
whenever I come to this show it really
is like Avatar The Last Airbender I just
feel like no I'm I'm in good hands I'm
not gonna be like like it almost feels
weird reviewing it even cuz it's like
when am I ever gonna say anything but
there's it's so rarely you know I still
rarely say anything bad about it even
why do say something bad it's like but
the show is not bad by any mean I try
think we ever saw a bad episode yet and
that's a private scenario is it for
so um and it's just every time I come to
it it's just like it's like seeing old
friends it's like here we go and here's
our next adventure it just makes me
makes me feel like a kid but I can
appreciate it as an adult because
there's just enough for both so yeah I
just love a man every single time it
comes on I just get warm and fuzzy
inside and I love these people and man
they just such good work um so yeah
can't wait for the next one uh we'll
definitely see you guys there
later eat boom of doom